why did you update your classic poem
about winter it was the 10-year
anniversary of when i wrote the first
one 10 years ago you didn't want to read
your own poem so you had jd read it he
[__] botched it i mean he was
giggling through the whole thing he
couldn't contain himself do you remember
that winter is when there are no leaves
on the trees
winter is when we say goodbye to the
virtue
[Laughter]
to the what
is that funny it's the truth what are
you saying
goodbye to the birds and the bees
after nearly five minutes of jd still
giggling i had to cut him off because it
was like getting ridiculous he could not
get through his sentence why did you
jd why it was a breakdown
why did you laugh so hard at ronnie's
poem i mean what was it it was insulting
to ronnie it was just funny it was uh i
never expected those words to come you
know out of i guess i should have but
you know
when i see birds and the bees and then
for hours
i mean
it made me laugh
i'm going to leave it in your hands
ronnie what is the best presentation for
your art you want to read it or do you
want jd to read it
i'd like i'd like jd to read it i think
it would be great all right jd do you
have a copy of it now in front of you i
do have a copy of it in front of me
right now and try and try and do it the
right way please like let really try to
read it put something into it all right
like i mean the guy i did work on it how
long did it take you to write this uh
two days
two days okay two days of this guy's
life and he's got five days left
probably two days
so you know if he took two days to write
it he's given us his time and nothing is
more precious toward the end of your
life than time so
by all means jd
winter
10 years later by ronnie mund
that's not funny come on j.d
[Laughter]
winter
there's still one hour of extras
[Laughter]
winter
no more leaves will be falling
[Laughter]
no more leaves will be falling from the
trees
i gotta interrupt you what is so funny i
mean there's another fee in trees
he put an apostrophe don't worry dude
don't worry about the ground hey just
read the [__] thing
winter
we never say goodbye
to the birds and the bees
what
what what does he mean by that all right
keep going
winter is when a deer
winter is when a dude in red shorts and
an uber car for a sleigh
drops to your gifts at your door and
runs away
[Laughter]
winter
is when snow never falls and we put on
our spring gear to ring in the new year
winter is when that special someone's
heart is given to you and tells you
you'll never part
good one
winter was never here you see
because vegas is where i picked to be
[Music]
winter the only thing that will change
for me
disease will spring ahead
one hour for me
what
yeah i like the old poem better you know
i always said most sequels suck but uh
this this did suck compared to the first
one there's a line in there that i
didn't understand what it had to do with
winter the uber driver thing too that
was messy it's not godfather part two it
was more part three than part two
ronnie puppet wrote a poem about winter
and would like to read it all right
here's a real poem okay let me hear
yours let me hear you winter
here you go ass wipe
winter is cold so bundle your [__] and
balls
so you can still blast squirt and come
all over the walls winter is when it
gets dark super early
which means it's got extra time for
eating out your girlie
winter is when jack frost explodes
leaving calm icicles on your gutters
from his hot frosty load
winter is when we build snowmen with
class
a carrot for a nose
and another in the ass
winter spring summer fall
every one of them is pleasing
so pull off your girlfriend's panties
now
because [__] is always in season
happy holidays [__]
69.69
[Applause]
[Music]
robert frost that puppet i love him
that's a poem ronnie get to work